[S01] 你知道吗？呃，我们平时就是总习惯把数据看作是某种静止的东西
[S02] 嗯，确实是这样
[S01] 对，就像一个，呃，装满水的湖泊，或者一个整整齐齐的文件柜你想啊，你可以随时走过去，打开抽屉，拿出一份文件仔细研究。这种静态的视角，怎么说呢，几乎主导了我们对信息系统长达几十年的认知
[S02] 没错，但当我们真正，呃，深入现代数字世界的底层运转机制时，你就会发现，那个平静的湖泊其实并不存在
[S01] 根本不存在，是吧？
[S02] 对，真实的数据世界更像是一条奔流不息的江河。就是说，数据就像时间一样，从来不会停下
[S01] 哇，这个比喻很贴切
[S02] 其实我们把每天结束时，呃，盘点一天的数据称为批处理的话，那么它就像是用一个桶，去河里打水，然后提回家慢慢分析
[S01] 就是只能看到某一刻的死数据
[S02] 没错，但在现代社会的节奏下，这显然不够了。我们必须在水流冲刷过岩石的那个瞬间，呃，就捕捉到它的流向
[S01] 所以，欢迎你加入今天的深度探索。在这次的知识解析中，我们要为你拆解被誉为数据工程圣经的巨著，也就是《设计数据密集型应用》的第十二章核心精华
[S02] 也就是业界常说的 DDIA
[S01] 对，我们要探讨的主题就是流处理，好吧，让我们来拆解一下。无论你是在为系统架构做决策，还是单纯对技术底层充满好奇，了解流处理都能为你提供一种全新的视角
[S02] 是的，它非常底层，但又无处不在
[S01] 没错，它会改变你看待手机APP推送社交媒体时间线的方式，甚至它会彻底颠覆你对数据库这两个字的传统理解。所以今天我们就来看看，数据是如何在无形中流动，被加工，并最终塑造我们眼前的数字世界
[S02] 那既然，呃，既然我们要探讨一条没有尽头的数据之河，首先要解决的就是运输问题
[S01] 对，数据怎么从一头到另一头
[S02] 是的，在流处理的语境下，产生数据的生产者和处理数据的消费者，他们的节奏往往是不一致的。这里最常见的一个系统瓶颈就是，生产者的发送速度，远远超过了消费者能够处理的速度
[S01] 这个我深有体会，比如双十一那种瞬间的流量高峰，那消费者那边肯定处理不过来。那面对这种速度差，系统一般会怎么应对呢？
[S02] 嗯，通常有几种策略，最简单粗暴的，要么直接丢弃一部分数据
[S01] 直接扔掉
[S02] 对，这在某些只看总体趋势的，比如监控指标里是可行的，少几个点不影响大局
[S01] 嗯，有道理。那不能丢的呢？
[S02] 不能丢的话，要么实施背压，意思就是反向限制生产者的发送速度，告诉他你慢点发
[S01] 等了，就是把压力传导回去
[S02] 没错，但其实大多数情况下，现代系统更倾向于使用缓冲，也就是把暂时处理不过来的消息，先放进一个队列里，这就依赖于我们要讲的那个消息代理
[S01] 也就是message brokers。我注意到，业界在这个消息代理的设计上，好像有两种截然不同的流派，对吧？
[S02] 对对对，分歧很大
[S01] 一种是那种传统的AMQP或者JMS风格，比如我们常用的RabbitMQ，另一种是基于日志的代理，最典型的代表就是Kafka，我感觉它们底层的运作机制差别非常大
[S02] 这其实是设计哲学上的根本分歧。呃，传统的消息代理，它的设计初衷是短暂的通信
[S01] 怎么个短暂法？
[S02] 它的机制有点像邮递员送信，你想，邮递员把信件交到你手上，只要你确认收到了，邮局那边就会把这封信的派送记录或者实体备份，直接销毁
[S01] 阅后即焚的感觉
[S02] 对，在系统里，这被称为破坏性读取。就是说，消息一旦被消费者是，成功接受，代理就会立刻把它从内存或者D存上删除
[S01] 这种机制的好处是不是代理本身的负担很轻，毕竟不用存历史数据
[S02] 没错，非常轻量，但代价就是数据转瞬即逝，没了就是没了
[S01] 嗯，就像碟从碟里那个五秒后自动销毁的任务简报，看完了就彻底没了
[S02] 哈哈，这个比喻非常精准。相比之下呢，基于日志的消息代理，比如Kafka，它采用了完全不同的做法
[S01] 它是怎么做的？
[S02] 它更像是一个怎么说呢，罩在玻璃后面的公共布告栏，生产者不断地在布告栏最下方钉上新的通知，这是一个只追加日志的过程
[S01] 也就是只能往后写，不能改前面的
[S02] 没错，而消费者们呢，就是隔着玻璃阅读的人，每个人手里都有一个记事本，自己记录着自己读到的第几行
[S01] 也就是所谓的offset
[S02] 对，这里非常迷人的一点是，这种读取动作不再具有破坏性了。因为日志被持久化在磁盘上，只要磁盘够大，它可以保留几天甚至几周的历史记录
[S01] 哇，这就完全不一样了。这有点像我家里的那种数字硬盘录像机，也就是DVR。只要我愿意，我可以随时把进度条拉回昨天，重新看一遍那些旧消息
[S02] 完全正确。这带来的直接工程优势就是，你可以由多个不同的消费者，互不干扰地读取同一份数据
[S01] 各看各的进度
[S02] 对，比如你们公司的分析部门，可以从头读取过去一周的数据去跑统计模型。同时呢，安全团队还在实时追踪最新的欺诈行为。大家用的是同一份原始日志，但互不影响
[S01] 这个太强大了
[S02] 而且更有价值的是，它为系统一代提供了巨大的安全网
[S01] 怎么说？
[S02] 你想啊，如果工程师写了一段新的数据处理代码，心里没底，完全可以在生产环境中，把这个新消费者的偏移量，直接重置到昨天
[S01] 用昨天的真实流量跑一遍
[S02] 对，用真实的流量，安全地进行测试。如果代码有bug跑崩了，也没关系，修复之后把偏移量再倒回去，重新跑一次就行了
[S01] 只要底层的日志文件还在，所有的历史就可以无限次的重演。这就引发了一个非常有意思的思考。呃，如果日志能够完美保存发生过的所有事件，而且永远只是在追加，那我们每天用的所谓的数据库，到底算什么？
[S02] 这是一个非常深刻的问题
[S01] 是吧？因为在传统观念里，我觉得数据库就是那个记录着世界当前状态的绝对真理。比如我的账户余额是一千块，它就存一千。今天花掉二百，变成了八百，系统就用八百覆盖掉那个一千
[S02] 对，这叫原地更新。但在流处理的哲学里，这种静态的状态并不是数据的本质
[S01] 不是本质，那本质是什么？
[S02] 本质是事件，它只是事件累积后的一个结果，导致状态发生改变的那些事件。比如你买了一杯二百块钱的咖啡，这个不可变的动作，这才是根本
[S01] 这让我想起书里的那个经典比喻，如果用数学来解释，应用当前的状态，其实是事件流对时间的积分
[S02] 没错
[S01] 反过来，事件流，就是状态对时间的微分。也就是说，数据库里存的当前余额，不过是所有历史交易记录累加之后的一个最终快照而已
[S02] 是的，这个理论在工程上的直接应用，就是我们常说的数据变更捕获，也就是CDC
[S01] CDC，这个现在很火
[S02] 非常火。在这套架构下，数据库不再是一个封布的保险箱了。数据库的每一次写入，更新，删除，都会立刻转化成一条不可变的事件流
[S01] 然后把这个流发给别人
[S02] 对，这条流可以实时同步给搜索索引，本地缓存，或者是数据仓库。所以从这个角度看，我们平时查询的那个数据库表，其实只是底层事件流的一个幻象
[S01] 幻象
[S02] 对，或者用更专业的术语说，它只是一个物化视图
[S01] 等等。如果每一次点击，每一次修改，甚至连购物车里拿进拿出的动作，全都作为不可变事件被永久保存的话，不管磁盘有多大，我们迟早会把地球上所有的硬盘都塞满了吧
[S02] 哈哈，这确实是一个非常严峻的物理限制，存储成本是个大问题
[S01] 那系统怎么避免崩溃呢？
[S02] 为了解决这个物理现实问题，流处理系统引入了一个叫做日志压缩的机制，也就是Log compaction
[S01] 是像ZIP文件那种压缩吗？
[S02] 呃，不是的，这里的压缩不是指用算法减少文件体积，而是基于数据的键，也就是key，进行逻辑上的合并
[S01] 能举个例子吗？
[S02] 如果我们把这和更宏大的途径联系起来看，比如你有一个记录短视频播放量的流，视频ID就是那个key
[S01] 嗯，一个视频，一个ID
[S02] 这个流里不断追加着播放量更新，先是一百次，然后一百零五次，最后是一百二十次。系统会在后台默默地扫描这个日志。当他发现针对同一个视频ID有多条记录时，就会直接丢弃旧的记录
[S01] 只保留最新的一条
[S02] 对，只保留一百二十次这个最新状态
[S01] 原来如此。所以对于财务账单这种需要无限追溯的事件，我们就保留完整历史。但对于那些我们其实只关心最新状态的数据，比如播放量或者用户资料，通过日志压缩就能把冗余的历史记录清理掉
[S02] 没错，这样就能把磁盘控制在一个合理的范围内
[S01] 但是，这里有个矛盾。既然日志是只追加且不可变的，如果遇到现在的隐私法规呢？比如GDPR要求彻底删除某个用户的数据，我们又不能直接拿橡皮擦去把旧记录抹掉
[S02] 这确实是个非常棘手的问题。因为不可变性碰上了法律要求可变。业界应对这种情况，通常会采用一种叫加密分碎的技术
[S01] 加密分碎，听起来很暴力
[S02] 意思就是说，在最初写入事件流的时候，我们就把敏感数据加密存储
[S01] 失锁起来
[S02] 对，当用户要求彻底删除时，系统其实不去修改那条不可变的日志，我们去修改什么呢？直接销毁解密这部分数据所需的密钥
[S01] 哇，这招很绝
[S02] 这样一来，原本的记录就成了一串永远无法被解读的乱码。在逻辑上，这其实就实现了真正的删除
[S01] 把删除数据变成了遗忘密码，这真的是非常优雅的一个工程妥协
[S02] 没错
[S01] 好了，接下来才是真正有趣的地方。既然所有的动作都可以被记录成事件流，那我们必然会撞上分布式系统里最棘手的一个幽灵，那就是时间
[S02] 时间在分布式系统里永远是个大麻烦
[S01] 如果一切都是按顺序追加的，那么网络延时带来的时间错乱该怎么解决？你想，事件发生的时间和server处理它的时间，往往存在巨大的鸿沟
[S02] 对，在流分析中，我们必须严格区分两个概念，事件时间和处理时间
[S01] 这两个有什么区别？
[S02] 事件时间是动作在用户设备上真正发生的那一刻，而处理时间呢，是server接收到并开始计算的那一刻
[S01] 听起来应该差不多
[S02] 差很多，因为有网络拥堵，设备断网等等情况。这两个时间不仅会有延迟，有时候还会导致事件的到达顺序完全颠倒
[S01] 确实，这就好像你在跨年夜网络拥堵的时候给朋友发短信，你连发了三条，结果朋友按三一二的顺序收到了。流处理引擎就像那个努力把前言不搭后语的短信拼凑成完整对话的朋友
[S02] 这个比喻很生动。书里也用星球大战的上映顺序做了一个很绝的类比
[S01] 哦，星战怎么了？
[S02] 你想，如果你按照现实中电影上映的处理时间来看，顺序是第四五六部，接着才是前传一二三部
[S01] 对，小时候看觉得剧情是断裂的
[S02] 没错，只有按照故事线内部的时间戳，也就是事件时间去看，从一一排到六，它的逻辑才成立
[S01] 所以，如果我们依赖服务器的处理时间来做业务监控的话，是不是会有很大问题？比如，计算每秒的请求量，一旦系统卡顿了一分钟，然后恢复了，那一瞬间系统去处理积压的日志，监控面板上是不是就会出现一个巨大的流量尖峰？
[S02] 绝对会。但实际上，用户的请求是非常平稳地发生的。那个尖峰纯粹是系统处理能力波动造成的错觉
[S01] 这种错乱太可怕了
[S02] 还不止呢，这种错乱还引出了一个更现实的工程难题，我们叫它滞留事件
[S01] 滞留
[S02] 假设你的流处理引擎正在计算过去一分钟的用户活跃度，现在时间已经到了三分零五秒，系统准备输出三分钟到四分钟的这个统计结果了
[S01] 嗯，看起来很正常
[S02] 但就在这时，突然收到了一条发生在上个月的事件
[S01] 上个月？
[S02] 对，可能是一个用户的手机断网了整个一个月，今天他突然连上wifi，把那个事件发出来了，你说系统该怎么处理？
[S01] 哇，这确实头疼。系统不可能为了等它，让所有下游的计算都无限期停滞吧，根本不知道这种延迟数据还有没有，或者什么时候来
[S02] 对，系统必须做出决断。通常的妥协方案有两种，一种是，如果数据延迟实在太久了，干脆直接作为误差丢弃
[S01] 直接不管了
[S02] 另一种连方案好一点，先按时发布一个当前的结果，不等了，等以后滞留事件到达后，再单独发布一个更正值，去覆盖之前的统计
[S01] 就像财务报表后面的修订案一样
[S02] 是的，不过更让人绝望的是，甚至连几点几分发生，这个时间戳本身，我们都不能轻易相信
[S01] 连发生时间也是假的
[S02] 你想，如果用户手机系统的时钟，他自己设慢了十分钟，那他发来的事件时间，从一开始不就是错的吗？
[S01] 天呐，那怎么弄？
[S02] 为了校准这种设备时钟的偏差，流处理引擎在设计时，往往需要记录三个时间戳
[S01] 哪三个？
[S02] 第一，设备记录的事件发生时间。第二，设备发送网络请求的时间。第三，服务器接收大数据的时间
[S01] 为什么要这么多？
[S02] 因为系统可以通过对底发送时间和接收时间，并且减去网络传输的预估耗时，就能推算出设备时钟跟服务器时钟之间的偏差
[S01] 然后再把这个偏差给补回去
[S02] 没错，倒推修正出真实的事件发生时间
[S01] 真是绞尽脑子啊。解决了时间校准，我们才能准确地把时间切成窗口，来进行流分析，对吧？我发现这里的机制其实非常有讲究
[S02] 是的，窗口机制是流处理的核心
[S01] 比如最简单的滚动窗口，就是把时间切成固定长度，互不重叠的块，比如一分钟一个。但它有个缺点，如果一大波流量刚好跨越了两个窗口的边界，数据就会被生硬地劈成两半
[S02] 对，为了平滑这种边界效应，我们会使用别的窗口。比如跳动窗口，它允许窗口之间有一定重叠，或者滑动窗口，窗口随着时间的推移，一点点平滑向前滑动
[S01] 我看书里还提到了一种非常智能的，叫会话窗口
[S02] 那个非常实用，它不是基于固定的时间长度来切分的，而是基于用户的活跃度
[S01] 怎么算活跃度？
[S02] 比如，只要用户持续有动作，这个窗口就一直延续。一旦系统监测到，比如说，超过半小时没有任何新事件了，它就判定这次会话结束了，直接关闭窗口并输出计算结果
[S01] 这个做用户行为分析太合适了。那梳理清楚了时间和窗口的机制，我们就要面对流处理中最硬核的挑战了。多流连接，也就是joins
[S02] joins在流处理里绝对是个硬骨头
[S01] 是啊，在静态的数据库里做join，只要查一下索引就行了。但在流处理中，这是两条永不停止的河流，你怎么让它们在奔涌的过程中准确对接？
[S02] 这里的核心难点其实在于内存状态的管理。我们以流流连接为例
[S01] 就是两个流拼一起
[S02] 对，假设我们要计算搜索广告的转化率，搜索动作是一个流，点击动作是另外一个流
[S01] 用户可能搜完之后过了半小时才去点击
[S02] 没错，所以流处理引擎必须在自己的本地内存里，维持一个状态缓冲，把用户的搜索事件暂时存下来
[S01] 等着点击事件过来配对
[S02] 对，当点击事件到来时，就去缓冲里寻找配对的记录，但是内存可是有限的
[S01] 存不下怎么办？
[S02] 引擎必须设定一个时间阈值，比如一小时，如果一小时后点击还没匹配上搜索，就必须把搜索记录从内存里强行丢弃
[S01] 为了防止内存溢出
[S02] 对，这是一种必须的妥协
[S01] 那如果是要把实时的行为流，和静态的用户档案连接起来呢？比如所谓的流表连接
[S02] 这个更有挑战。如果流引擎每处理一条洗位事件，都要通过网络去查询一次用户数据库的话
[S01] 数据库肯定会被巨大的并发请求直接压垮吧
[S02] 绝对的。所以，通常的做法，是利用我们前面提到的那个CDC技术，让流引擎直接订阅用户数据库的变更日志
[S01] 哦，数据库刚过来
[S02] 差不多，就是在引擎所在的本地内存里，维护一个实时的用户档案副本
[S01] 这样一来，连接操作就从低效的网络请求，变成了极速的本地内存查询
[S02] 哇，很聪明的做法。其实我们还漏了一种，表表连接
[S01] 对
[S02] 比如维护推特的时间线，一条流是推文的发送，另一条流是用户关注关系的变化，这俩都在不断变更。流处理器必须时刻盯视这两条流，无论是谁发了新推文，还是你关注了新的人，都要立刻计算出结果，然后更新到你的时间线缓存里
[S01] 逻辑非常复杂
[S02] 所以，这一切到底意味着什么？当我们讨论这么多复杂的内存状态，缓存和连接时，我必须替听众问一个最致命的问题
[S01] 你问
[S02] 假设四副器在进行流表连接的半途，突然断电宕机了，重启之后，因为底层的日志是持久化的，所以消费者肯定会从上一个存档点重新读取，对吧？
[S01] 对，接着读
[S02] 但如果它恰好读取的是一笔扣款指令呢？系统不就重复执行了吗？我是不是买一杯咖啡会被扣两次钱？这对于业务来说是灾难性的吧
[S01] 你触及了流处理容错机制里最核心的痛点，这就引出了一个重要的问题
[S02] 是什么？
[S01] 为了防止买一杯咖啡扣两次钱这种情况，现在流处理框架必须保障一个极其严格的SEM，叫做恰好一次，也就是exactly once。并且它必须重度依赖一个概念，叫幂等性
[S02] 幂等性
[S01] 对，幂等性的意思就是一个操作无论执行多少次，最终的效果和只执行一次是一模一样的
[S02] 能举个生活中的例子吗？比如电视遥控器，把音量调大一格，这就不是幂等的
[S01] 因为按十次，声音就太大了
[S02] 没错，但把音量设定为五十，这个操作就是幂等的。你按一次是五十，按一百次它还是五十
[S01] 我明白了，那在系统里怎么实现？
[S02] 在流处理中，系统会给每一条消息分配一个单调递增的偏移量ID。下游系统在写入数据库准备扣款的时候，会先检查这个ID
[S01] 看它处理过没有
[S02] 对，如果发现ID为九五二七的扣款指令之前已经执行过了，它就会直接忽略这次重试，绝对不会扣你第二次钱
[S01] 也就是说，框架通过VP次或者定期生成自动槽档点，再结合下游的这种幂等操作，用极小的性能代价，完美解决了崩溃重启带来的重复副作用
[S02] 完全正确。甚至有些高级的框架，能够将读取消息，处理状态，写入输出，推进偏移量，这四个动作，直接打包成一个原子提交
[S01] 要么全部成功，要么全部失败
[S02] 绝不留下任何中间状态。正是这些底层机制，赋予了流处理系统在混乱的网络环境和随时可能崩溃的硬件条件中，依然保持数据绝对准确的能力
[S01] 真的非常精彩。今天我们彻底推翻了数据是静止湖泊的陈旧观念，看到了数据作为奔流江河的真实面貌
[S02] 是的，真是一个范式的转变
[S01] 我们拆解了基于日志的消息代理为何能提供强大的容错和重放能力，也发现了传统数据库其实只是事件流，物化后的一个瞬时切片
[S02] 没错，物化视图
[S01] 我们还理清了事件时间与处理时间的巨大偏差，探讨了各类时间窗口的机制与妥协。最后，我们深入剖析了系统是如猴通过状态缓冲，进行复杂的流连接，并利用幂等性和原子提交，在崩溃中守住数据一致性的底线
[S02] 这是一个涵盖了理论与工程实践的深度旅程。其实在结束之前，呃，我想把视角稍微拉远一点
[S01] 哦
[S02] 聊给你，也就是正在听的你，一个在哲学层面上的思考
[S01] 说说看
[S02] 今天我们花了很多时间讨论事件溯源和流处理中的不可变性。只要发生过的事情就永远记录在案，绝对不能被直接抹去。哪怕系统犯了错，我们也只能追加一条纠正事件去进行补偿
[S01] 这，这的确让人联想到我们人类的心智与记忆。你想，你生命中经历过的那些痛苦，尴尬或者严重的错误，其实就是你人生的原始日志
[S02] 非常贴切
[S01] 它们是物理发生过的不可变事件，你根本无法在脑海里强行按下删除键
[S02] 抹不掉的
[S01] 但就像流处理系统不需要被庞大的原始日志压垮一样，我们所能做的，其实是不断去经历新的事件
[S02] 比如什么样的新事件？
[S01] 比如进行一次深刻的反思，做出一项改变，或者经历一次心理治愈。我们将这些全新的补偿事件，追加到我们生命的时间流里。随着时间的推移，我们的大脑也在后台执行着Lock compaction
[S02] 也就是Lock compaction
[S01] 没错，那些痛苦的细节被慢慢压缩，合并，最终沉淀为一个更加成熟，更加平和的当前状态，也就是我们此刻的人生物化视图
[S02] 生命的流只能向前，永远追加，但我们可以决定最新状态的模样
[S01] 这句话说得太好了。下次当你想强行遗忘某段过往时，不妨用流处理的思维想一想，或许你需要做的不是试图删除那本旧日记，而是去勇敢地产生一条强有力的补偿事件。感谢你加入今天的深度探索。在这个数据如江河般永远不为停歇的世界里，希望你能继续保持对事物底层逻辑的好奇心。我们下次知识解析，再见
[S02] 再见